put your hands up heads up he's got his
gun he's still got the gun
right down I think I hit him a suspect
is dead after a gun battle with police
in a wooded area of Hawaii the incident
happened on September 23rd in Cal Hawaii
according to the Hawaii Police
Department officers responded to a
report of a man seen with a firearm
following a domestic argument with his
brother officers say they were alerted
the suspect was hiding on the dead
inside of a wooded residential area body
camera footage captured by one of the
officers who responded to the scene show
officers arrived to a small gate in
front of the property and one can be
heard saying they've been to the
property before
yeah he does like to run I've been here
before I remember now the officers then
one by one climb over the gate and make
their way through the grounds
location from
YouTube
the officers then approached the home in
a single filed line through the wooded
area
as they get closer to the home one
officer can be heard giving a signal to
the others
move the cover
remove the cover and call out or what
you want to do
once in a covered spot an officer calls
out to the suspect they've got the place
surrounded if the place around it come
out with the hands up to it now
the police
got movement
you're probably gonna run out the back
corner
we got you surrounded
seconds later officers run after the
suspect running
[Applause]
the officers then follow toward the
suspect who enters a forest-like wooded
area located behind the home up
that's a pig that's a pig yeah that's a
pig
moments later gunfire erupts
shots fired shots fired
Mill party uh bareback Captain pants
running towards 27th let's solid shots
fired no gun scene though
you guys good
this is 915
copy
Scott are you good
after confirming his fellow officers are
okay police continue their hunt for the
suspect the son of what came from the
left
yeah we're good
let's let's move up there they're still
giving commands
less than a minute goes by and officers
see the suspect and draw their weapons
still got the gun
roll to your stomach
checking
checking role to your stomach the
officers repeatedly yells to the suspect
to follow their commands and then more
gunfire erupts he was right down in the
slowly scooted back
[Music]
the officer continues to give the
suspect verbal commands from behind a
tree before another gunfire Exchange
over here
come to 27th clear the radio
[Applause]
lie down I think I hit him
foreign
to one another the suspect is down
however at the moment it was unclear if
the shot was fatal the Hawaii Police
Department says they attempted to
perform First Aid on the suspect who was
identified as 30-year-old kaina keoho he
was pronounced dead at the scene the
Hawaii Police Department says no
bystanders or officers were hurt at
standard practice the police department
says their Internal Affairs unit is
reviewing the incident and all of the
officers who fired their weapons were
placed on administrative leave pending
the investigation reporting for the long
crime Network I'm Elizabeth Milner